(applause)
- I love when you come on!
I love it! We both have blue on.
(Kelly laughs)
Um, so I heard that you have
a collector's item at home.
Okay, Super Bowl-winning quarterback
(Henry gasps)
Patrick Mahomes-
Yes! Signed a jersey for you.
- He did!
- Yeah
- So, I..
- I was at that Super Bowl.
- I just talked about him
- Yup.
- on Rich Eisen Show.
- Yeah!
- And so then I said to him,
and I, I said, you know,
if he ever comes to my house,
he would get, like,
a chicken stuffed with ricotta and spinach
with a reduction sauce.
- What?
- And then he, Rich Eisen,
played that for Mr. Mahomes.
- Yeah.
- And I was invited to a
game here at SoFi Stadium.
I walked down on the field.
He comes running up to me.
This is a very big person.
- Yep.
- This is about six or
seven people in one.
(audience laughs)
And here's the thing, you
know when you hug somebody
and your finger, you push in,
and there's a little give.
- [Kelly] Yeah, not with-
- No give.
- Yeah.
- [Henry] No give,
it's like a can.
- So like my body, yeah.
- It's like a can of soup!
- [Kelly] That's hard.
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah, hard.
And he said, "I've got
a surprise for you,"
and he gave me his jersey.
- That's so cool! I love that.
- [Henry] Okay, yeah!
It's great.
He gave me his shirt.
- Did you have the dinner?
- Huh?
- Did you-
Did invite him to dinner?
- Okay so, this is the thing.
So now he runs off, now,
he's gonna to play a big game,
hitting and running and
throwing and hurting and,
and you know-
- All the things.
- Yup.
- And just before, as he
runs off, he turns around,
he goes, "I'm gonna take
you up on that dinner."
(audience whoops)
And he's gone!
When?
- Okay. Well-
- I'd like to know when.
- He had to win a Super Bowl first.
- [Henry] He did.
- Yeah.
So when you're not hanging
out with NFL stars,
you're also writing kids books.
So you're doing another, a new series now.
- We have a new series
coming out, but in October.
So you have to remember this.
A little duckling lives on a,
on a, on a pond in New Hampshire,
and she is feisty.
And she dreams about being a detective.
- Oh, I like it already.
- And she has a best
friend who's a salamander
who reads comic strips that are left
by the humans at the campsite.
- Okay.
- When they get too soggy,
these bits of comics,
he uses them as a washcloth.
(Kelly laughs)
- I love it!
- And her dad,
she's the only duckling
with a dad who is a beaver,
because her egg came down the stream,
and kind of got stuck in
the dam of the beaver.
- So she was raised by a-
- [Henry] By a beaver.
- That's a great story.
- Beaver McBeaver.
- Beaver McBeaver!
We were out of options!
- Lin Oliver and I have written it.
It is our thirty-eighth novel together.
- You're such a successful writer!
Which is such a great story,
because, I know we've covered this before,
but it was interesting,
'cause I literally was driving my daughter
to school yesterday, and she's dyslexic.
And you have told me that
you're dyslexic as well,
and I find that amazing
to tell my daughter that
you've written like 40
books and you're dyslexic.
'Cause she was getting bullied,
like, at school for not being able to read
like all the other kids.
- [Henry] What grade
is she in?
- She's second.
(Henry gasps)
But, but they said-
- I have books for her!
- I know I have, I've been reading.
- Oh, yes!
- Yes, yes!
So wait, but I,
but this is the coolest
- Kelly Clarkson
- [Kelly] thing, though!
- Has my books!
- Her, her school,
her school actually, um,
did a whole thing on
dyslexia the morning before,
and they pointed out-
- 1 out 5 children!
- [Kelly] I know!
So it's, it's more common than,
I didn't, I didn't know that.
But they,
they were pointing out-
- [Henry] She's in the tribe!
I know, and they were
pointing out, you know,
Captain America, Anthony
Mackie is dyslexic.
Like, Shazam, like,
Zachary Levi's dyslexic,
you're a dyslexic.
They was showing all your pictures Yeah.
And everything that y'all done,
and like, just the
success of that, and she
it really empowered her that
y'all are so open about it.
It empow-
- [Henry] What is her name?
- [Kelly] River.
- River!
- [Kelly] Yeah!
Here it, River!
I got it!
(Kelly laughs)
- Okay.
- How you learn
has nothing to do with
how brilliant you are.
- Oh!
(audience cheers)
Fine.
- It's fine.
(Kelly laughs)
We're fine.
It's fine.
My makeup artist is gonna kill me.
It's so nice. Oh!
- You look good.
- [Kelly] Yeah, totally!
- Nothing is dripping!
- [Kelly] Not everyone looks great crying.
- You don't look like Giuliani at all!
(Kelly laughs)
- I also don't look like Rachel
McAdams from the Notebook,
so I'm trying to handle it.
You don't just write kids books though,
so you're also working on
your autobiography, right?
Do you like this?
'Cause, is it nerve-wracking?
- Oh, this,
this was nerve-wracking.
- Okay.
- My son Max,
I have three wonderful children,
Jed, Zoe, and Max.
Max has said to me for years,
"Dad, you should write an autobiography."
And I went, "Oh, I don't think so.
I don't know what I have to say."
- Yeah.
- Honest to God, and,
and that's not hyperbole.
That's, that's the way I feel.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he kept on saying it.
So I called my agent, Esther
Newberg, for some reason,
and I said, "Esther, you know,
my son keeps saying to me,
'I should write an autobiography.'"
She said, "Is your phone with you?"
I said, "Yes it is."
We hung up.
A few hours later:
"Okay. So it'll come
out in, in October..."
- Oh my gosh!
"...of 2023 and
get on it."
- Get on it!
- "This is the deal, and that's it."
And it's coming out in October 31st,
the day after my birthday.
- [Kelly] That means that
there's a demand for it.
Oh, that's a wonderful-
- [Henry] Oh my god!
- [Kelly] That's wonderful!
I love this picture!
(audience cheers)
- "The Fonz and Beyond"? I love that!
- Now, it's not printed yet,
or every one of you would have it
under your stool.
- [Kelly] Aw!
(crowd aws)
- That's amazing.
- But, it, it,
it's only the picture, so
I put the picture-
- Was it daunting to do it?
- Daunting.
Now I can't do it by myself,
in the same way that
I work with Lin Oliver
on the children's books.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I worked with James Kaplan on this
and I, he, I had to fly him out here.
Oh my god.
I, I had to take him to restaurants
(Kelly and audience laughs)
and, but anyway, he said we-
- Take him to dinner!
- Oh, take him to dinner?
All three meals!
(Kelly laughs)
And, but anyway,
well, I spoke to James for about 60 hours.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And then the book is there.
- That's, it's such a, is it
like a memory lane? Kind of?
- [Henry] It is a memory lane.
- Yeah.
- Because of what I do,
I have remembered some of it,
but some of it is brand new.
that I was all,
"I haven't thought about that in years!"
- That's what I'm saying,
it must have been-
Yeah, be like a trip.
- [Henry] You know?
- Yeah.
Well you have met so many
people in this industry.
- I have.
- You've worked with
so many people
- [Henry] A lot of people.
- in this industry.
So do you think if we named-
just, if we...
- Try me!
- ...threw some random names at you?
- Try me, here we go.
- Could you give us a story?
- Okay. I'm in a booth.
- [Kelly] Okay.
Okay. You're in a booth, okay.
Okay, well, we go big here.
So let's call this segment
"Henry's Hollywood Roulette".
♪ Hollywood Roulette ♪
(applause)
Okay. Okay.
So, thank you Justin for the button.
I'm gonna hit this button,
and whatever name the
roulette wheels lands on,
Henry has to tell a
story about that person.
If you, if you have one.
- If I know one.
- Okay. Okay. Here's,
here's the first one.
Here we go.
(ball rolling)
(dinging)
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
Okay. Dolly Parton!
- Dolly Parton!
- [Kelly] I love Dolly.
I love her.
- [Henry] Dolly Parton is
not the queen of music,
she is the queen of the universe.
- [Kelly] I love her.
(audience cheers)
And the kindest person ever.
- Okay.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I'm just beginning
my directing career.
I am chosen to direct her
first television movie.
"A Smokey Mountain Christmas."
- Yeah. Oh yeah.
- With nine children, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Okay.
Oh, that's so nice that two people saw it.
(Kelly laughs)
Okay, and,
she was adorable.
She is powerful.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She is so smart.
And again, plays 92 instruments.
- [Kelly] So talented.
- Okay. So I, I directed it, and I,
and the head of NBC at that
time, Brandon, um, uh...
- [Audience] Tartikoff!
- Thank you!
Brandon Tartikoff
- Okay.
- came up to me 'cause our kids
were at the same preschool.
And he said, "Good morning, 34 Share."
Which meant that we got a gigantic share,
when it was aired on television,
of the viewing audience.
And I...
- [Kelly] Wow!
- I knew that way, it was successful.
- Oh, that's awesome!
- [Henry] Yes.
I didn't know Brandon's name,
but I knew that movie
was successful.
- But that's peak! Yeah.
Do you know what's funny though,
is everybody describes you as
the nicest guy in Hollywood,
I think she is the nicest
woman in the industry.
She's probably the kindest
thing you could run into.
- [Henry] Oh my god.
- She's so nice.
- And so filled with this...
- [Kelly] And like, real.
- [Henry] Yeah. Yeah.
- Like authentic.
And has real conversations with you that
aren't like vacant.
- [Henry] Oh my god.
- And can do what she says she does.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Whoop!
- [Kelly] Absolutely. I know.
Okay, next one, here we go.
♪ Who will it be? ♪
Oh well, Bill Hader.
- Bill Hader, I know.
- Yeah?
- Bill Hader gave me a life.
I was 7, 27 when I got the Fonz.
(audience member whoops)
And then I auditioned for Barry,
and, which is going on,
in just a little while.
- Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- For the fourth season.
- [Kelly] So exciting.
- And I, and Bill Hader and Alec Berg
said yes to me when I was
72, to play Gene Cousineau.
- I, well of course they would swat-
- Well, I, not, not, not necessarily.
- So for those who haven't caught up,
what's happening on Barry?
- Okay.
I can't tell you because they'll kill me.
- Okay. Well nice to have y'all today!
- But, oh so, here I am,
I'm driving across the country.
Gene is, you know, I, I
turned him in last season.
- [Kelly] Yep.
- Hoohoo. Because he killed my girlfriend.
- That's a solid move.
Yeah, he turns, yeah.
- [Henry] Oh you got to, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- Oh, I loved her, Janice.
So I'm driving across the country!
I'm going through Kansas!
There is corn all around me!
All of a sudden a cop car
comes from the other direction!
- [Audience] That's it?
(audience laughs)
- Are you? That's a great tease.
I'm like, "And?"
- Not only is it a tease,
I just made it up.
(all laugh)
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
I was like, "And what happens?"
While we do have a clip,
that was incredible.
- [Henry] Thank you.
Here's Henry Winkler
in "Barry", everybody.
- His arm around my grandson,
death in his eyes.
And then I realize,
he's not in charge.
I am.
I know how to press those buttons.
Hey, I installed them.
"I love you, Barry."
"You do?"
"You betcha."
"Can you say it again?"
"Sure, why not?
I love you."
"Mr. Cousineau, I would do
anything for your forgiveness."
(audience cheers)
- Season four of "Barry" is on HBO,
y'all be sure to check it out!